Guten morgen tim.
Das sind zwei themen von denen ich nicht gedacht hätte dass wir sie zwanzig neunzehn noch diskutieren würden.
Aux
Logbuch netz politik nummer dreihundert und achtzehn frisch auf den tisch am dreiundzwanzigsten oktober zweitausendneunzehn mit alten kamellen alten bekannten und äh ja,
dj ü s meeren aus der vergangenheit dinosaurier.
Wir könnten eigentlich immer so aufkleber machen ein logbuch netz politik.
Ja genau gibt's hier heute ja.
Bezahlt ja sollen wir erstmal ein bisschen feedback besprechen.
Macht sich immer ganz gut ist ja auch ein gewisser hinsicht alle kabeln.
Ich bin ganz froh.
Ich werde jetzt mal schon.
Wenn wir wenn wir so inhaltliche korrekturen bekommen bin ich immer ganz angetan dass die so
einfach sauber recherchiert direkt mal zu also ich schreib euch mal kurz die ganze geschichte hin,
finde ich sehr gut weil das heißt dass uns informierte leute zuhören und weil wir das verhältnis mäßig selten kriegen,
habe ich den eindruck dass wir verhältnismäßig gut recherchieren.
Deswegen freue ich mich immer wenn wir so ausführliches feedback bekommen haben in der vorletzten sendung zwei fehlerchen eingebaut.
Das war absicht.
Ne weil ich kann auch.
Finde den fehler.
Der erste fehler war,
und da habe ich auch gezweifelt da war ich wende mich da danach hat mir der zweifel und zwar kann ich dir genau sagen dass ich dachte immer über diese kinderspiel debatte das haben wir ja schon auf dem schulhof damals diskutiert und wir hatten uns darauf gibt verständigt dass
die erste auslöser der kinderspiel debatte in deutschland,
amoklauf von.
Winnenden gewesen sei da hab ich das jetzt genau und das war eigentlich denn,
es war der von erfurt und der hat am sechsundzwanzigsten april zweitausendzwei stattgefunden,
als ich noch ein kleiner junge war und da habe ich nämlich dann zweitausendzwei diskussionen auf dem schulhof.
Siehst du mal deswegen hast du das auch weil ich war da schon genauso alt.
Können wir dich.
In der nerd ecke auf dem schulhof mit unseren tornister und unseren großen brillen.
Während die coolen kinder zigaretten auf und schnippen haben wir uns,
urteil.
Nee also für mich war das halt so täglich grüßt das murmeltier mäßig um eine weitere assoziationen kette hier fortzuführen.
Aber es stimmt schon ne erfurt war äh das große ding darauf wurde dann mehrfach hingewiesen du hattest schon kurz nach der sendung.
Hast du schon so war das.
Mehrere.
Sehr viele hinweise bekommen ich habe in der bei der gelegenheit nochmal dann den wikipedia artikel dazu ich dadurch gelesen,
diese dieser amoklauf das war,
ich habe zu den abiturprüfungen hat der junge da in die schule gerannt und hat irgendwie primär auf leer körper geschossen aber auch kommilitoninnen getötet.
Da gab es eine ganze reihe an diskussionen im weiteren verlauf spezifisch die über killer spiele die dann auch darin endet mündet dass es.
Ein neues jugendschutz gesetz das ohnehin schon in arbeit farbe das dann irgendwie beschleunigt wurde,
einige wochen später verabschiedet wurde und eine verschärfte regelung eben für.
Ego shooter und funktionale gewalt eingeführt worden außerdem auch eine verschärfung des,
waffengesetze denn der hatte,
eine waffenbesitzkarte oder der hatte formal die voraussetzung für eine waffenbesitzkarte trotzdem hatte er,
die waffen die er da verwendet hat eine pistole und eine flinte irgendwie unter komischen nicht sauberen umständen,
erst verstanden und nicht sinnvoll eingetragen.
Jetzt fangen wir wieder an uns schlecht zu erinnern aber war dass er erfurt ding nicht.
Richtig der vater hat auch waffen besessen das war auch meine erinnerung aber ich lese in der in der wikipedia seit
zweitausend war also hier ist der name genannt stein häuser mitglied in einem schützenverein außerdem legte er die erforderliche prüfung ab
um in den besitz einer waffenbesitzkarte zu kommen in den monaten vor der tat kaufte er sich die beiden tatwaffe munition und verschiedene ausrüstung gegenstände magazine holster und ähnliches die zum erwerb nötigen behördlichen eintragung,
in der waffenbesitzkarte sowie die von ihm für die erlangen dieser eintragung beigebracht,
unterlagen die aus fertigung dieser unterlagen
durch zuständige vereins organe oder anlagen betreiber und die für die erlangen der unterlagen von stein häuser gemachten angaben entsprachen jedoch nicht den anforderungen des deutschen waffen gesetzes,
er wusste vermutlich dass die eintragung seiner waffenbesitzkarte gesetz wirklich waren erlangt worden waren und somit war der kauf illegal aber der hat die.
Die verkaufen institution hat hier den entscheidenden fehler gemacht.
Ja es gab also ich kenne das waffengesetz nicht gut genug.
Der moment doch äh sogar genau deine frage ist geäußert der kauf der beiden tatwaffe erfolgte nach späteren untersuchungen auf grundlage der nötigen eintragung in der waffenbesitzkarte von stein häuser und war somit aus sicht des verkäufers legal
er meldete den weiterverkauf licht gemäß den behörden
diese hätten aufgrund dieser meldung wegen der mutmaßlichen fehlerhaften eintragen der waffenbesitzkarte,
die waffen unverzüglich von stein häuser einziehen müssen also der verkäufer hat sich,
korrekt verhalten der käufer hat sich in korrekt fallen ich kenne die details nicht,
wie das mit diesen waffenbesitzkarte läuft aber.
Sowas auf jeden fall gab es viele diskussionen um was denn jetzt der grund ist dass er alle seine rolle umbringt und natürlich killer.
Interessant die schützen haben sich da waren bei weitem nicht so in der in der in der öffentlichen,
in der öffentlichen in öffentlichen zwiegespalten oder prüfung wie die gamer ne aber,
es gab sowohl änderungen interessant es gab eine änderung des jugendschutz gesetze hat schon gesagt
ergänzung des waffen gesetzes die irgendwie bei schützen unter fünfundzwanzig jahren eine medizinische,
psychologische untersuchung verlangen und bestimmte waffen gar nicht mehr erlauben
es gab änderung des thüringer schulgesetzes.
Es gab änderungen der landespolizei gesetz in thüringen und das hatte also sehr ausführliche sehr ausführlichen,
after maß diese ganze geschichte zweiter fehler,
und auch hier etwas wo ich zu unserem schutz sagen muss etwa ein thema was wir eben nicht recherchiert haben sondern nur spontan in der sendung erwähnt haben die ganze geschichte mit blizzard auch da haben wir von mehreren in den kommentaren korrekt
korrekturen bekommen das war ein motor dominik und falk die sich da spezifisch hervorgetan haben und per e-mail hat uns aber auch noch rolli geschrieben
oder rolli der das ganze noch ein bisschen ausgeweitet hat auf die china konflikte also china in china blizzard.
Und das lese ich jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz vor der general manager das ist der sportdirektor also nicht der trainer das war unser erste fehler der justin rockets,
moore hat ein statement geriet bietet der dass er natürlich mittlerweile,
das ist besonders markant da die rockets das größte aushängeschild der in china sind es ist also nicht irgendein team sondern
da dort mitte ende der zweitausender jahre ming ein chinese groß aufgespielt hat basketball ist wie in vielen anderen sozialistischen geprägten ländern,
balkan baltikum auch in der china volkssport nummer eins der chinesische fernsehen hat nach dem retreat das komplette preseason programm der gestrichen die ist gerade in der saison vorbereitung war auch globale,
vorbereitungsspiel in japan und china angedacht waren
die standen zudem noch auf der kippe wurden aber nun durchgeführt einige chinesische sponsoren wollt mit der nichts mehr zu tun haben wodurch logos von spielfelder,
entfernt werden muss noch dazu das haben wir nicht erwähnt stimmt kam die aktuelle south park folge die china mal wieder stark kritisierte,
der kommission der hatte sich daraufhin für den retreat von molly entschuldigt und empathie für das beteiligt sein.
Der chinesen nach diesen äußerungen geäußert die beleidigt sein nicht beteiligt beleidigt sein die hat sich aber auch dazu bekannt dass meinungsfreiheit zu den verlust der gezählt.
Zählt der,
präsent rockets,
on matters important in amerika ist es natürlich sehr kontrovers,
deshalb weil die sich auf die fahne geschrieben hat.
Für uns um freie meinungsäußerung zu kämpfen zuletzt konnte die bei der affäre um den football profi,
ach das war genau das war der der sich immer hin,
viel zuspruch gewinnen als die sich hinter panik stellte als dieser aus protest an der us-regierung bei der nationalhymne vor dem spiel niederknien.
Was vor allem donald trump,
tief emotional berührt hat und so weiter und so fort mittlerweile mittlerweile hat die chinesische spitze der presse allerdings verboten sich über die,
negativ zu äußern china hat sich dem stellenwert der auch durchaus bewusst und weiß dass es hier zu keinem nachvollziehbaren kompromiss für beide seiten kommen kann zum thema blizzard eigentlichen auslösen den fehler.
Kurze anmerkung also du hast ja hier immer wieder hat sich ganz gut wir geben die ist halt auch.
Ist richtig sehe von den großen populären sportarten in den usa also ich jetzt nochmal ein football,
dazu zählen würde ist es natürlich die sportart die am stärksten auch von der schwarzen,
bevölkerung vom schwarzen mitgeprägt ist.
Ja die weißen jungs in der hätten können das nicht alleine aufrecht erhalten den betrieb also können die auch aber.
Man weiß dass ihr einfach die besten gestellt haben den großteil der besten sohn und das deswegen hast du da eine ganz andere kultur während halt so des american football natürlich einfach eine extrem weiße geschichte ist und das gilt weitgehend auch für baseball.
Wobei auch da,
also sehr zentrale athleten des football sports.
Da ändert sich so aber die prägung ist ist ist ist eine andere.
Die kulturelle prägung des spiels.
Von daher ist es natürlich für die besonders schwierig sozusagen jetzt hier,
auf diesem pfad zu kommen dass ihn auf einmal menschenrechte wegen geld egal sind oder klar ist halt auch multi milliarden unternehmung und,
man kann vielleicht auch gleich generell nochmal was zu china sagen aber fahr doch erstmal kurz vor.
Zu beliefert das besagte spiel war nicht world of warcraft sondern ein trading kart spiel das sind diese,
trading card ist gut wie nennt man das lucy box oder also diese diese spiele die.
Wo das eigentliche ziel des spiels ist dass man mehr geld ausgibt um der schwitzt um karten für dieses spiel zu kaufen egal also.
Da es war also nicht ein computerspiel sondern ein trading karte spiel das ist dann sowas wie magic oder sowas ne.
Es ist ein online sammelt karten spiel das heißt auf walk rafft ist sozusagen hier der untertitel da kam wahrscheinlich die konfession her.
Ja okay also ich ich gebe das jetzt einfach wieder wenn man merkt ich habe wirklich keine ahnung von rollenspielen.
Basiert sozusagen auf of warcraft ist quasi so ein world of warcraft begleitendes system.
Schreibt das alles nochmal gut nieder kurz gesagt wurde der spieler blitzt schulung,
nach einem turnier interviewt und hat sich auf die seite der,
protestanten glaubt der proteste der demokraten in hongkong geschlagen diesem wurden danach seine zehntausend dollar preisgeld entsorgt und er würde für ein jahr vom offiziellen spielbetrieb ausgeschlossen.
Das ist natürlich für ein pro gamer ganz schön scheiße lustig hierbei,
ist eine statue vor dem headquarter von blizzard auf dem meinungsäußerung als eine der säulen des unternehmens deklariert wurde mittler mitarbeiter haben diese aussage dann abgeklebt,
und es wurde über twitter zum boykott blizzard aufgerufen.
Gut ich glaube tatsächlich ich habe in anderen kommentaren dann noch gelesen dass diese situation ein bisschen von blizzard auch nochmal entschärft wurde.
Aber ich denke der der punkt ist einfach gemacht dass es hier ein dass wir hier in zunehmend eben in probleme kommen.
Ja und das problem heißt einfach.
No-go kommentierte später später.
Nach großen protesten zurück und reduzierte die sperre auf sechs monate und entschied sich das preisgeld doch noch auszuzahlen da gibt's auch ein offizielles,
das statement das morgen da noch verlinkt in einem kommentar der später geschrieben wurde,
vielleicht wusste rolli das zu dem zeitpunkt noch nicht so haben wir.
Haben wir hiermit herzlich danken für die korrekturen mit aufgenommen.
Ja das ist das problem das nochmal.
Ist halt einfach die realität china.
Wir erleben jetzt einfach dass das dass wir eine weltwirtschaft haben in in der,
ein viertel der konsumenten aus diesem einen land stamm und dort einfach politisch die dinge anders gesehen werden als in vielen anderen teilen und oder weniger wichtigen teilen der welt,
unten unternehmen,
sport entertainment et cetera disney ist er ja genauso drin gefangen also jetzt insbesondere eben diese welt konzerne die ihre produkte weltweit platzieren und das darin auch sehr geübt sind.
Haben sicherlich schon immer auf die ein oder andere art und weise auf die befindlichkeiten des jeweiligen marktes acht gegeben.
Nur dass es halt jetzt im falle von china in so bereiche vor stößt wo halt,
insbesondere amerikanischen unternehmen halt auch immer so ein draus gemacht haben wie selbst in den noch ihre us values am herzen liegen weil es ist natürlich etwas was man als unternehmen auch immer gerne
von sich gibt egal wie sehr es stimmt ja ist halt einfach.
Laufen sie da ein probleme und die frage ist wie wie reagiert man da jetzt richtig drauf verzichtet man drauf kann die sagen auch.
Okay ihr wollt euch nicht mehr ausstrahlen und keine werbebanden mehr buchen.
Euer ding so wir wir leben aber hier unsere videos und ohne videos gibt's ja irgendwie auch kein basketball,
wird sicherlich nicht so gesehen aber natürlich dann so ein bisschen auf die fälle davon schwimmen sieht und eben auch viel geld und weiß der geier welche verträge sie vor allem in diesem zuge schon abgeschlossen haben,
also inwiefern sie gezwungen sind in gewisser hinsicht hier auch zu reagieren das weiß weiß ich nicht weiß nicht ob überhaupt irgendjemand das weiß.
Und die frage ist natürlich auch das ganze ging ja auch von der diskussion jetzt im apple das war eine ausgangspunkt ne was könnte die unternehmen machen in dieser situation.
Scheiße finden ist aber sehr einfach nur angenommen wäre jetzt.
Chefin von so einem großen tech unternehmen und dann kommt so die frage ja was denn hiermit viertel des weltmarkt des.
Ja die.
Machen wir denn da ne.
Haben nicht apple aktien gekauft weil sie meinungsfreiheit so geil finden die haben apple aktien gekauft weil sie rendite geil finden,
und die werden da jetzt fällt es schwer zu argumentieren und natürlich ist es für eine marke die will natürlich immer sicher wir sind hier sehr wir stehen ja für werte das gehört ich meine das ist ja,
eine marke ja könnten ja auch die computer verkaufen ohne apple drauf zu schreiben,
man baut sich da eben ein satz aus,
symbolkraft und,
wer gefühlten werten auf und das sieht immer scheiße aus wenn man guckt wie diese diese iphones hergestellt werden wie die nike schuhe genäht werden und sollte man immer einen schlechten eindruck.
Ja aber die sind eben nicht in der welt um also man sieht's ja auch hier gerade an markus katharina das apple nicht unbedingt dafür,
mehr existiert damit wir spaß an unseren computern haben sorry.
Da spricht der frust aber es ist natürlich 'ne generelle frage und ich denke auch nicht dass es keine möglichkeit gibt jetzt.
Eine reaktion zu zeigen gegenüber china.
Nur die liegt halt nicht darin dass man sich jetzt bei in anführungsstrichen kleinigkeiten groß auf punkt wo man.
Eigentlich nicht viel zu gewinnen hat.
Sondern eher darüber nachdenkt wieso langfristiges engagement aussieht also gerade im technikbereich speziell bei apple was halt die situation.
Siehst du das dass sie da nur ein paar iphones verkaufen bauen die scheiße da die hängen großräumig von den ganzen,
infrastrukturen und produktionsstätten die dort existieren ab und es gilt auch bei leibe nicht nur für apple das gilt nahezu für alle ich meine wann habt ihr das letzte mal ein elektronik produkt gekauft wo nicht mehr.
Da müsst ihr echt mal in euch gehen ist nicht viel.
Da wird einfach der großteil an elektronik heutzutage produziert klar hier ab und zu mal kurz aus vietnam und dann hast du mal was aus taiwan und.
Etcetera p p und japan haben sich auch noch ein bisschen was zu melden aber der großteil des schiffs und vor allem der großteil von so sachen die man eigentlich nicht braucht kommt irgendwie von da das heißt diese ganzen.
Liefern systeme und produktionssystem und das ganze know-how was china ja mittlerweile auch aufgebaut hat was ich ja nicht ohne,
das abzuschütteln ist ein prozess der geht über jahre und jahrzehnte,
und sicherlich müssen unternehmen darüber nachdenken wie sie alternativen aufbauen weil solange sie diese abhängigkeit haben von china werden wir so ein verhalten noch öfter sehen.
Freunde.
Könnte noch nicht mal einen guten ratschlag geben wie sie das vermeiden sollte weil diese illusion dass amerikanische unternehmen von so etwas vollkommen frei sind.
Ist auch vollkommen absurd ja da sind halt nur andere sachen die wir jetzt so nicht sehen die,
auf die da einflüsse wenn da die politik oder die öffentliche meinung der meinung ist irgendwas wär jetzt mal nicht okay und so da kriegt dann genauso schnell weg,
wo es dann vielleicht eben zugunsten eines anderen landes ist so was was ich hier jetzt sagt er hier die wie die araber sind alle sind gar nicht alle terroristen seid ihr denn drauf.
Also da ist immer spannend zu sehen wer den ersten stein.
Dann haben wir noch eine.
Komm ich vom steinwurf nicht zum sechsunddreißig c drei,
ich wollte ich suche gerade nach einer ein steinwurf.
Nur ein steinwurf entfernt.
Ein steinwurf von leipzig entfernt findet der sechsunddreißig c drei statt der sechsunddreißigste cash communication kongress des chaos computer clubs wie
schon quasi immer am vom siebenundzwanzigsten zwölften bis dreißigsten zwölften vermutet dass die ersten kongresse nicht so lange.
Immer aber ja.
Siebenundzwanzigster bis dreißigster es wurden inzwischen gibt es ein sehr ihr könnt also einreichung machen und zwar noch bis zum sechsundzwanzigsten zehnten dreiundzwanzig uhr neunundfünfzig.
Also drei tage ist es auf release.
Genau da bitten wir euch um einreichung wenn ihr denn signifikant ist mit der welt,
zu teilen habt der fdp ist verlinkt,
da wird die in den in der regel öfter schon besprochen haben falls ich das jetzt einfach mal kurz und bitte euch die track beschreibungen wenn ihr denn,
einreichen möchtet zu berücksichtigen da ist gut erklärt nach welchen einreichung gegen die teams,
suchen es gibt außerdem die vorverkaufstellen online,
am achten november um zwölf uhr am,
am zehnten november um siebzehn uhr und am einundzwanzigsten november um einundzwanzig.
Das sind die drei öffentliche vorverkauf phasen die uhrzeit spielt dabei durchaus eine rolle weil diese vorverkauf phasen üblicherweise jeweils nur wenige minuten dauern aufgrund,
des großen ansturm es gibt außerdem gerade schon die,
phase also die vorverkaufskarte fase wo menschen mit einem code sich bereits ein ticket kaufen können somit außerhalb dieser,
engen öffentlichen vorverkauf phasen ein ticket kaufen können diese bau tschau.
Bekommt ihr in den packers spaces eures und unseres vertrauens also die sehr viele communitys werden da von den team mit,
versorgt das heißt wenn ihr irgendwie kontakte habt zum lokalen chaos oder,
anderen gruppierungen dann lohnt es sich dort mal anzuklopfen.
Und nach deutschland zu fragen ich sehe auch dass einige gruppierungen wie zum beispiel oder so dass auch öffentlich bekannt machen dass sie,
über botschaft für bestimmte gruppierungen oder personengruppen verfügen und ich sehe auch immer wieder leute auf twitter die irgendwie freundlich fragen ob ihn denn jemand,
seine seinen zweiten workshop zur verfügung stellen kann denn wer auch alles watsche hat sind die speaker und die engel,
des vergangenen kongresses also diejenigen die als engel,
so ab sechzehn stunden oder so freiwillige arbeit dort geleistet haben die kriegen ein baustein wenn sie den eingelöst haben bitte ein weiterer draus also es gibt da gerade ein sehr ein,
of trust an dem man sich beteiligen kann und ich glaube viele wege führen dorthin sich daran zu beteiligen denn nicht ganz so effiziente wie ich aus meiner beobachtung ist sich auf twitter lauthals darüber zu beschweren was das alles für assis sind,
die leute die machen so wie ich das sehe tage lang ohne dass sie sich nachher freudig bekannt geben dass ihn das jemand auf sie aufmerksam geworden ist und ihnen ein bauteil gegeben.
Um vielleicht gleich den üblichen verdächtigen die jetzt diese diskussion wieder aufgreifen um immer wiederkehrende argumente in die welt zu wissen gleich mal noch was zu entgegnen.
Das bedeutet nicht dass der club unter sich bleiben will.
Das bedeutet nicht dass man irgendwie sich nicht öffnen will oder sonst irgendwas dieses wort das system gibt es und ist auch über mehrere jahre langsam so in.
Diese form gebogen worden die man heute hat.
Einfach um,
zwei dinge die sich so ein bisschen widersprechen unter einen hut zu bekommen auf der einen seite.
Die große nachfrage nach dieser veranstaltung irgendwie in die richtigen bahn zu lenken so,
damit es kein zufall das ding ist wir hatten als es losging dass die nachfrage größer war als das angebot in berlin immer wieder die situation dass.
Ticketverkauf war dann irgendwie überlaufen als technisch erstmal 'ne weile nicht funktioniert dann war das quasi nicht gewollt dermaßen aber dann faktisch wie es sich dann technisch ergeben hatten so eine so eine batterie.
Und das führte dann eben dazu dass,
leute die schon lange dabei waren die regelmäßig dabei waren auf einmal keine gelegenheit mehr hatten an dieser veranstaltung teilzunehmen,
was dann wiederum in der folge ganze community auseinander gerissen hat weil manche sich dann gesagt haben hier bin aber die und die person nicht dabei,
dann komme irgendwie einfach alle nicht verdamme wie kann kein spaß dran der anderen seite will man natürlich auch ganz bewusst.
Neue gruppen auch haben und auch dafür dient diese fortschritt system weil das ja nicht nur jetzt an leute gegeben wird die schon.
Dass wir eben über diesen weg auch ganz bewusst gruppen ansprechen,
vielleicht noch nie da waren oder die ihrerseits leute erreichen vielleicht erstmal gar nicht so auf die idee jemals gekommen werden dahin zu kommen und dann darüber so ein bisschen,
die karotte vor die nase gehalten haben weil weil wir einfach bestimmte kultur räume.
Explizit auch einladen den kongress auch für sich ova zu machen.
Ich also die idee dass eine veranstaltung mit siebzehntausend besucherinnen irgendwie unter sich bleiben würde besteht ja den nachtest nicht,
insofern brauchen wir nicht länger darüber zu diskutieren natürlich.
Das kam aber auch beim camp und da ist es aber im prinzip genau dasselbe.
Ja wer bist du noch unangenehmer ihre verhältnis zwischen angebot und nachfrage aber was wir haben auch dieses jahr wieder lange darüber diskutiert mit dem,
team was den vorverkauf macht welche,
ja welche probleme gibt es wie können wir die besser lösen das eine problem was sich nicht lösen lässt ist es gibt eine anzahl,
besucherin die wir zulassen können und es gibt eine anzahl nachfragen der personen diese beiden zahlen sind nicht gleich und wir müssen gucken wie wir die wie wir da eine auswahl treffen.
Die menschen 'ne 'ne halbwegs tiere möglichkeit bietet an diesem community event teilzunehmen,
und natürlich ist es wenn man ein community event macht was dieses auch mit siebzehntausend besucherinnen immer noch ist,
besucht man nach optionen sicherzustellen dass teile der community zu dem community event auf jeden fall kommen können und der weg der sich da bisher als der beste herausgestellt hat sind nun mal diese
ketten und die,
ich nehme durchaus jedes jahr menschen zur kenntnis die das für unter ihrer würde,
halten nach so einem workshop mal zu fragen und irgendwie kurz ihr ihr bestand,
ihre eigenschaft als bestandteil der community auch mal zu nutzen oder unter beweis zu stellen oder zu prüfen,
und ich sehe gerade in dieser community so ein also man kann sich das wirklich anschauen die leute die auf twitter irgendwie freundlich fragen die,
twittern vierundzwanzig stunden achtundvierzig stunden später hier ich habe ein ticket
dass diese community funktioniert und wer sich da irgendwie freundlich einfach,
mit das spiel mitspielt da sehe ich in der regel sehr sehr sehr fröhliche glückliche.
Tweets dazu und das kernproblem lässt sich eben nicht,
abbestellen es ist auch ein bisschen interessant als wenn man sich überlegt was dieses vorverkaufsstellen wie viel arbeit mühe auswertung ja da sind wir so richtig
daten getriebene des vorgehen ja dann irgendwie so der durchschnittliche wie lange müssen die phasen sein ne wie lange wird die botschaft kette wo funktionieren diese systeme wo funktionieren die nicht können wir das ändern indem wir mehr watch ergeben die.
Also ne wie können wir den prozess besser abdecken dass das hier schneller auch die tickets verkauft werden leuten die sicherheit zu geben natürlich gibt es auch das problem ne irgendwie ich kann ja ein hotel erst dann buchen wenn ich 'n ticket habe das ist ein fehler den ich.
Die muss jeder für sich selber machen würde nicht machen,
sowohl ticket als auch hotel wird man ja sehr sicher,
wieder los das heißt keines von beiden ist eine fehler investition.
Naja genau schaut mal schaut mal rein,
im lokalen hey guck mal in eurem lokalen communitys schaut mal auf twitter.
Es gibt immer viele möglichkeiten.
Eine gute gelegenheit mal sich die lokalen struktur mal genauer anzuschauen könnten nette leute dabei.
Könnte sein oder was ich auch ganz interessant finde ist so diese engel die jedes jahr einfach ein workshop kriegen die scheinen irgendwie.
Woher zu kommen.
Die kommen die kommt vorher ne und die haben ja auch schöne zeit dort also das ist immer.
Irgendwie gibt es viele leute die das irgendwie hinkriegen so.
Reden wir über das worüber du meintest nicht mehr reden.
Darüber redest du tim.
Ich habe ja lange noch drüber geredet.
Ja ich auch.
Aber bei der spd muss man halt auch wirklich die schon mehrfach begraben mehrfach wieder auf buddeln drehen,
und wieder zuschütten.
Ja wie ihr vielleicht gehört habe die spd sucht die super vorsitzenden ja also jemanden.
Der oder die,
in dem feier beides weil sie davon träumen jetzt einen präsidenten fast gesagt vorsitzenden den bärchen zu wählen,
also jemanden der breit ist quasi dieses kamikaze kommando spd vorsitz zu übernehmen,
ich wundere mich dass sie überhaupt noch jemanden finden aber ich wundere mich nicht so sehr dass es so schwierig ist und um das mal wieder so richtig schön demokratisch zu verankern haben sich gedacht,
haben wir mal urwahl geht aber leider nicht erlaubt das parteiengesetz so in der form nicht.
Das ist eine urwahl wir sind nur schrei oder wir sind nur knall.
Oder wie geht nur weil begriffe klären hier.
Wie das geht eine urwahl ist sozusagen von von der von den niedrigsten mitglieder ebene an also in dem fall halt alle mitglieder der spd nur sagt halt das parteiengesetz vorsitzender müssen vom parteitag gewählt werden.
Und dementsprechend hat man sich auf den modus eingelassen ne da machen wir noch eine nicht bindend der abstimmung,
lassen uns dass das in verschiedene kandidaten pärchen antreten und die beiden die am besten abschneiden die kommen dann,
in den parteitag zur wahl.
Das auch nicht gesichert ist dass das auch am ende wirklich so läuft.
Weil es ja nicht bitte am ende kann er irgendwie.
Schöneres als ne nicht binde wahl ne das ist doch auch irgendwie so eine.
Frau großbritannien.
Ja ist doch wirklich so ein blöder hütchen spieler trick ja deswegen ich bin und wir machen das dann lasst es sein wirklich dann lasst es sein,
vor allem weil ihr dann nachher noch mit kosten argumentieren ja warum nicht ist teurer als ne nicht binde wahl weil sie unsinnig ist sorry.
Na ja okay aber über die über die preise haben sich natürlich auch gedanken gemacht weil es sehr teuer.
Können wir noch diesen silber machen von dem jetzt mal alle alle reden es ist ja ein nicht enden wollenden nehmen bei politikern das alles was mit computer zu tun hat ist modern ja,
außer die infrastruktur in deutschland dafür bereitstellen um zu benutzen ist nicht so modern.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so modern dass man's anstreben sollte man redet gerne drüber aber man macht es halt nicht so sehr wenn's eins ums wählen geht da sind dann sozusagen alle auf einmal vollkommen euphorisch sprich,
die spd hat beschlossen wir machen das aber mit.
Weil dann muss man nicht so viel post durch die gegend schicken spart geld ist also,
das muss man so aus.
Irgendwie eine lösung geholt die auch zuletzt schon in der schweiz gescheitert ist na weil das was im urlaub der demokratie unter die räder kommt das kann für die spd nur gut genug sein.
Passt doch einfach,
perfekt ja wie faust aufs auge ja und jetzt gibt's halt viel viel aufregung christopher lauer hat in seinem block die diskussion,
losgetreten mit dem schönen titel warum die spd ihre wahl komputer zur wahl der parteivorsitzenden,
ausschalten muss dem kann man eigentlich weitgehend nur beipflichten natürlich gab es dann wieder eine entsprechend offene diskussion auch der c hat vor dem online-voting der spd gewarnt.
Ähm ja und was sagen wir dazu wir sagen leute was,
was was habt ihr eigentlich eine sehr bisherigen diskussion nicht verstanden ja also es ist muss man das eigentlich immer wieder alles erzählen.
Falls man das einfach mal ganz kurz zusammen das problem bei diesen wahlen ist immer.
Sie können später zurecht angezweifelt werden und ihr untergraben einfach die integrität jeder wahl und,
so eine unterscheidung mit na ja das ist ja gar keine richtige wahl ist ja nun eine meinungsbild fragen oder das ist ja nur eine abstimmung oder es ist ja ein.
Der gag ist weißt du das ist eigentlich der arbeitsmodus der spd das ist ja keine
binden de wahl jetzt also bitte wir sind jetzt hier in der koalition das ist bundestagswahl das ist jetzt kein wind verbindliches wahlprogramm was wir da vorgelegt haben.
Selbst wenn also ist ja nicht so ja das was im wahlprogramm steht es.
Ich habe es jetzt nicht bindend tim ich bitte dich stell dir mal vor was das kosten würde wenn das wahlprogramm der spd binden wäre das können wir ja nee das machen wir dann machen wir jetzt das machen wir jetzt digital.
Genau also es gibt immer diesen glauben dass das,
das ist ja schon okay wäre weil es wäre ja keine richtige wahl,
könnte man jetzt hier auch ein paar zur wahl stehende oder in dieser abstimmung,
als kandidaten stehende personen auch zitieren das ist halt natürlich ist es eine wahl,
eine wahl und man will dass die leute abstimmen will sich sicher sein dass die leute geheim daran teilnehmen können man will sich sicher sein dass ihre stimme auch gezählt wird und nicht nur das irgendein counter hoch gezählt wird natürlich auch genau der richtige counter.
Und das kann man einfach mit computer nicht garantieren.
Also man kann man keine show garantieren aber dann kann man nicht garantieren dass die wahl geheim ist.
Richtig man kann nicht alles garantieren sondern immer nur zwei von drei sachen.
Entweder nachvollziehbar und geheim dann,
gerne digital und nachvollziehbar dann aber eben nicht geheim gerne auch,
digital und geheim dann aber nicht nachvollziehbar.
Um mal alle per motivationen die der spd hier zur auswahl,
kurz zu zu rezitieren.
Viel spaß liebe spd es ist wirklich es ist bedauerlich eigentlich ne weil und vor allem muss natürlich muss auch so eine abstimmung geheim sein,
stell dir mal vor was das in so 'ner in so einem hierarchie und macht gebildet wird der spd bedeutet wenn du weißt wer dich gewählt hat oder wer nicht wenn dann irgendwann im bett parteivorsitz bist dass du wie du willst hier,
was weiß ich außenminister werden,
in dem in der großen koalition mit der cdu du weißt wir haben nicht so viele plätze und die werde ich sicherlich nicht hier so 'n genossen geben der,
der hier heimlich der der so und so wählt wenn er meint nicht beobachtet zu werden.
Wir haben natürlich relativ viel kritik eingesteckt dafür dass wir,
dass wir das hier kritisiert haben denn uns wurde eigentlich nahegelegt wir sollten einfach dafür sorgen dass böhmermann das ding gewinnt und gut ist,
die voraussetzung dafür hat der c tatsächlich es gibt ja die einen wunderschönen vortrag von es gibt eine wunderschöne forschung von sarah jamie luis sie das vor.
Ich hab im letzten jahr als dieses cyber voting debatte oder war das dieses jahr direkte noch in dieses jahr mit rein die cyber worte in debatte in der schweiz aufkam wurde mich genau dieses system,
zur anwendung kommt und louis hat kürzlich ein vortrag gehalten ausgerichtet vom fc schweiz wo sie nochmal ihre technischen erkenntnisse zu diesem sky system da.
Beigetragen hat dass eben mit wenig überraschung auch noch eben vollständig kaputt ist jetzt ist sarah luis aber auch nicht unkritisch zu sehen weil sie,
schon die meinung vertritt sicheres everything wäre möglich und sich wünscht dass die schweiz hier ihre vorreiterrolle gerecht würde,
insofern hat sie vielleicht trotz ihrer ganzen technischen forschung die
ohne jeden zweifel über über jeden zweifel erhaben ist vielleicht noch ein grundsätzlich.
Noch nicht in den fundamental schluss aus ihrer forschung furchen also quasi die schweiz weiterhin zu ermutigen so etwas überhaupt zu tun kann ich dann,
vor dem hintergrund ihrer forschungsergebnisse nicht,
nachvollziehen weil ob das system jetzt sicher ist oder nicht ist am ende für das demokratische argument sogar unerheblich weil die.
Sie meinte in dem statement auch ja das wäre ja so ein äh eine herausforderung die man annehmen müssen in der größenordnung von der damaligen mondlandung so nach dem motto man stürzt sich jetzt mal.
Die war ja auch gefälscht genau wie die wahl bei der spd.
Stanley cobra.
Dahinter.
So ja wahrscheinlich kann man sich tatsächlich so ein szenario vorstellen ja wo so zehn jahre lang so die besten
computer spitze
so loggen politikwissenschaftler und was weiß ich wie man da noch alles mit einbinden könnte in so ein unfassbar teures projekt einsperrt und dann zwanzig jahre darüber beratschlagen wie denn das so ein wirklich
zu holen ist unheimlich viel geld verpasst wie viel prozent des bruttosozialprodukt wurde für die wohnung mondlandung drauf gegeben wo ich dann aber sagen muss.
Was war jetzt nochmal genau der vorteil den man hat.
Wollten wir geld sparen.
Wollten wir geld sparen oder oder oder läuft's am ende nicht darauf hinaus dass man die wahl ja eigentlich auch trotzdem mit papier hätte machen können wenn es mit dem computer nur zehn minuten früher rauskriegt oder sagen wir mal ein tag.
Aber das ergebnis ist dasselbe der unterschied mit der zur mondlandung ist ohne den aufwand den man treiben musste für mondlandung gab es keine mondlandung,
ohne den aufwand die man treiben muss um ein irrer witziges und ich würde sogar sagen wo unklar ist ob das auch am ende erfolgreich und projekt zu treten für zu treten für 'ne kryptobereich.
Hat man am ende dasselbe wählen können wir auch jetzt schon.
Er ist nicht nur also diese diese herausforderung des things ist jetzt nichts,
wo es sich lohnen würde zwei
sich fundamental gegenüber stehende gesellschaft systeme in ein wettrüsten zu führen bis sie irgendwann eins von beiden untergeht dass wenn ich im zweifelsfall die demokratie die sich im wettrüsten um die mondlandung irgendwie auf dem weg zum cyber voting für galoppiert
während andere einfach ordentlich arbeiten.
Ja man sieht ja jetzt auch schon wie das im im kampf um die stimmen jetzt schon läuft ja also wo
etwas mit einsteigen wo die russen die öffentliche diskussion mit beeinflussen wo unternehmen wie cambridge analytica alle register ziehen
irgendeiner form eine eine beeinflussung vor der abgabe der stimme zu machen in dem moment wo man aber die abgabe der stimme,
direkt angreifen kann kann man sich sogar das sparen das sogar noch billiger.
Wir haben jetzt auch auseinandersetzungen wahlergebnisse in bolivien venezuela etcetera wo eben auch schon teilweise wahlkampf oder zum einsatz kommen,
ich vermisse auch in der öffentlichen diskussion in der berichterstattung der journalisten einfach diesen hinweis darauf indien gleiches thema also.
Irgendwie ist es immer noch nicht angekommen,
dass wir hier ein problem reinlaufen wir können uns mal wieder glücklich schätzen dass dass wir das in deutschland zumindest erstmal nicht haben ja nur es bisher halt auch der spd untersagt werden den demokratischen prozess auf diese art und weise durchziehen.
Es muss die spd müsste aus ja gut die spd müsste so so fangen viele sätze an die sind in der regel war,
selbst wenn das argument nun,
tragbar wäre dass es sich ja hier nur
um eine nicht verbindliche abstimmung handelt und nur um die wahl zur spd-vorsitzende was ein job ist der eine halb derzeit von irgendwie vier monaten hat und weit von viel,
politischem wirkt potenzial entfernt ist ja selbst wenn man das alles runter spielt ist das einer der städten tropfen die den stein höhlen,
ein solches verfahren irgendwann einmal auf einer relevanten ebene zu etablieren und deswegen ist das auch so problematisch das ist genauso wie,
ein bisschen alltags rassismus zuzulassen oder ein bisschen schwanger das geht eben lang mittelfristig gut führt zur,
normalisierung von solchen
in akzeptablen systemen und verhaltensweisen deswegen macht man das nicht das macht man nicht als fußballclub wie ist dieser fußballclub der damit baden gegangen ist.
Vfb stuttgart.
Vfb stuttgart das macht man wenn es wenn es sich für einen fußballclub schon nicht ziehen dann,
muss die spd eben überlegen in welchen kreisen sie agieren möchte mit ihrer demokratie.
Also es ist wirklich eine unfassbar zur öffentlichen offen zu schau getragene fortwährend inkompetenz demonstration die hier getätigt wird und,
ein gott wie wie viele tiefschläge wollt ihr eigentlich noch.
Wie viel wie viele diskussionen wollt ihr noch führen in denen ihr auf jeden fall verliert einfach nur weil ihr sie führt.
Ja ihr seid ihr seid wirklich der schwarze ritter alles politisch tablet moment ja der also wirklich mit zwei abgeschlagen armen und beim so also rum vor sich hin zog dann sagt irgendwie ist doch nur eine fleischwunde.
Also,
unglaublich sagt ja auch nochmal bringt auch nochmal den böhmermann ein gedankenexperiment eine beliebige person nennen wir sie jan böhmermann tritt auf dem wahlparty tag auf und behauptet im stil früherer,
einfach dass sein team die abstimmung gehackt hätte also allein diese behauptung wird ne und,
dann vielleicht mit ja und wir haben dann auch die einflussreiche computer club zu rate gezogen ohne namen zu nennen so ja irgendwann glaubt halt,
und das ist fast noch schlimmer weil wenn wir erstmal in diese situation kommen dass die leute dann auch noch den wahlen nicht mehr glauben meine,
ansatzweise sehen wir das auch schon bei trump und das muss einfach ein ende haben also bitte liebe spd,
fangt ihr endlich mal an.
Wir haben eine gute nachricht hast du eine gute nachricht channel.
Oh ja aber.
Wir haben ja ich kann's ja kurz dazu erzählen wir haben tatsächlich ja gesagt es wäre gut wenn wir jede sendung versuchen eine gute nachricht haben wir manchmal eine gute nachricht haben,
wäre es ja schön wenn wir eine gute nachricht single hätten und wir haben auch mehrere einsendungen bekommen.
Eine davon ist aber besonders heraus gestochen und deswegen haben wir uns überlegt diese dieses single dann auch tatsächlich zu zu nutzen,
zwar kam das zu uns hat das den weg zu uns gefunden von,
christian von den drogen boys ja die drücken voice machen,
ja was ne.
Irgendwas betrügen halt.
So und die haben ich google die mal kann man direkt verlinken.
Und den haben wir jetzt genau beugen boys haben ein band camping,
musik artige musik wie ihr auch hört und deswegen ist es mir eine große freude jetzt zur guten nachricht.
Aux
Was ist denn die gute nacht.
Die gute nachricht ist eine darknet seite wurde,
und zwar die darknet seite mit dem namen ur kam,
die offenbar eine der,
größten darknet seiten für dokumentieren kinder ist kindesmissbrauch war.
Und die gute nachricht ist da wurde jetzt ein dreiundzwanzigjähriger südkoreaner verhaftet der diese seite angeblich von zuhause aus betrieben hat
und die gute nachricht ist nicht nur das hier geht nämlich weiter denn,
weder musste ein verschlüsselte messenger mit einem staatsstrukturen versehen werden noch brauchte irgendjemand eine lücke oder irgendwelche hacking organisation im staatlichen auftrag sondern dieser,
ist einfach an sich selber gescheitert was ja auch etwas ist auf der sich regelmäßig hinweise bei kriminellen see scheitern eben,
er an sich selbst er hat zwei fehler gemacht und zwar hat er im quält text dieser seite die über einen hinten service zugänglich war also ein,
tor hinten service der also über das tor netzwerk zu greifbar ist und sich über das tor netzwerk versteckt wo man also die tatsächliche ip-adresse nicht kennt.
Er hat in dem quält text dieses,
dieses services den ihr dort betrieben hat eine echte ip-adresse versteckt gehabt steht hier geschrieben ich,
verstehe das folgendermaßen wenn man so einen hinten service konfiguriert dann schreibe,
im prinzip in deine tor configure rein okay dieser hinze ich möchte einen hinten service haben und der soll weiterleiten auf folgende adresse und da kann man
sogar 'ne harte p a dressel angeben oder also wer ahnung hat macht's halt mit einem lokalen socken
das heißt du hast in der regel deinen tatsächlichen web service lokal laufen oder in einem internen netz laufen,
und davor einen.
Anderen service der den hin service.
Das hab ich übrigens auch in dem vortrag nochmal erklärt du kannst alles hacken du darfst dich nicht erwischen das habe ich genau nochmal erklärt wie ein hinten service zu betreiben sei,
so und jetzt hat er nämlich folgenden fehler gemacht sein service den er dort betrieben hat der wusste offenbar seine eigene ip-adresse.
Und hat vielleicht ließ er nur lokal hat aber irgendwie in seine eigene in seinen eigenen quält text wahrscheinlich beim erstellen eines links in der testversion oder sonstigen auf sich selber verlinkt,
und dabei seine ihm über sich selbst bekannte ip-adresse genutzt.
Ja oder also klassiker sind auch so fehler seiten ja dann steht unter der fehler seite drunter was weiß ich.
Jan sechs null unter,
w w w d e ja weil weil man ihn horst namen mitgeteilt hat oder sonstiges ja also dieser server hat quasi kenntnis gehabt von seiner tatsächlichen ip und hat diese p irgendwo in seinem text,
verraten.
Das war der erste hinweis den hat hat die polizei gefunden haben aber auch er hat aber auch noch eine hacker crew gefunden die das gemeldet haben und.
Die weite der weitere fehler war er hatte also das war eine kommerziell betriebene seite da brauchte man,
konnte man sich zugänge holen die haben so einen preis gab von fünfzig euro im monat also dreihundert euro für ein halbes jahr kriegt man bip account mit dem man unbegrenzte downloads von dieser seite hatte und da wurde man,
zu einem anbieter rübergeschickt wo gesagt wurde hier kannst du jetzt,
bitcoin bezahlen der betreiber hatte natürlich auch bei diesem anbieter sein bitcoin wallet.
Und alle bezahlung ging an das gleiche wallet und wenn man sich dann dieses wallet angeschaut hat,
dann hat er von dort aus immer an ein anderes wallet übertragen von dem er dann sich das geld hat auszahlen lassen
und mit diesem wallet hat er das auszahlen hat er natürlich auch über den bitcoin challenge gemacht bei dem haben sie dann oder bei ich glaube sogar bei diesem bitcoin change da haben sie dann einfach angefragt haben gesagt sag mal,
wem gehört er da war er registriert mit seinem namen,
seiner handynummer und seine e-mail-adresse jetzt hattest du also zwei sehr eindeutige hinweise erstens die ip-adresse die auf ihn registriert war das wallet von dem er die auszahlung auf sein konto vorgenommen hat
war auf ihn registriert und so haben sie den typen dann eben geschnappt beides wie gesagt fehler auch das mit dem roller fehler die wir in dem in unserem vortrag,
du kannst alles hätten dass ich nicht erwischen lassen besprochen haben deswegen bin ich,
immer erfreut wenn prognosen zu treffen insbesondere wenn sie betreffen bin außerdem natürlich hier wieder erfreut über die ausgezeichnete polizeiarbeit die zu loben,
nicht aufhören kann und ich bin erfreut dass eine solche scheiß seite aus unserem schönen darknet verschwunden ist und deswegen hab ich das jetzt zur,
zur gute nachricht ernannt ist in ordnung oder.
Da kann ich in dem zusammenhang noch kurz das ist ja auch so eine sache ich hab vor ein paar wochen war ich bei der spiegel redaktion weil die mich für einen podcast eingeladen haben.
Ja zwar heißt der podcast das netz fragt oder sowas,
das netz hat fragen eigentlich ein ganz interessantes podcast konzept hätte man selber drauf kommen können die suchen sich ein thema und gucken dann was irgendwie auf gute frage,
google suche vervollständigen und so dafür fragen zu auftauchen laden sich leute ein die davon ahnung haben,
stell dir diese fragen also ich war ja quasi so sowieso fragt auf gute frage punkt net,
und dann musste ich darauf antworten eigentlich keine schlechte idee für eine sendung ziemlich gut sogar.
Mehrere fragen.
Ja ja mehrere.
Also es ging nicht nur um stark net sondern.
Nee doch du ging warum wird das darknet nicht verboten kriege ich meine drogen auch wirklich geliefert so ganz normale ne ganz normale service fragen ja ganz normal.
Trauben die dann auch was und so ja.
Guten tag wir sind die besser oder schlechter ne hab ich vierzehn tage rückgaberecht nach bgb oder klasse.
Dann wichtig natürlich klar dass er auf dich gekommen sind.
Klar dass sie auf mich gekommen sind den der podcast wurde nur wenig geschnitten der teil an dem ich sage,
ob die drogen auch tatsächlich ankommt kann ich natürlich nicht sagen dass woher soll ich das wissen ich könnte mir aber vorstellen dass es ja durchaus eine nachfrage und ein angebot gibt dieser teil wurde rausgeschnitten möchte wo ich.
Noch nie gemacht ja.
So so was wollen sie denn offen lassen nicht dass die leute an der.
Es wurde aus redaktionellen erwägung entfernt aber natürlich nicht nur das ja also ich komme natürlich,
der termin war vorher klar es ist natürlich in der woche wo gerade irgendwie kinder pornos seite hochgenommen wir,
in der darf ich dann auf spiegel de erklären wie es nicht funktioniert.
Und sagt dann auch so was was ist denn das übelste was es im darknet gibt und dann,
ja da darf ich dann das geld ich dir aber vorher sagen können dass das da noch mal irgendwas dickes zum darknet kommen würde ne.
Na ja genau da war ich zu gast hab ich habe ich auch mal in den shots verlinkt das letzte hat fragen wie arbeiten drogen märkte im darknet
und dann hatten war schon vor einiger zeit vor ein paar wochen das haben wir ja auch nur kurz erwähnt aber nicht wirklich verlinkt im sender garten zu gast.
Zum zum sendung marathon die sendung ist glaube ich viereinhalb stunden lang.
Vier stunden neununddreißig und achtundfünfzig.
Ernsthaft ich dachte dass dir die fünf stunden marke gerissen okay.
Also eine eine freak show möchte man sagen tatsächlich auch auf verschiedenen ebenen eine,
genau das ist auf jeden fall auch nochmal verlinkt war ich zu gast hab mich hiermit.
Und ich habe auch hier und da was gesagt aber ich war eigentlich nur als technik support zwischendurch mal hier im studio.
Ich weiß ich habe das ja der wetter ebene aufgenommen tim war vorher kurz da nachher kurz da und dieses nachher da haben wir dann gleich noch eine stunde weiter podcast ist was nicht es nahm kein ende.
Nee so lang war 's nicht aber geht das auf jeden fall.
Schöne grüße an den senegal.
Und äh da das ja alles aus dem ruder läuft mit der politik und dem internet.
Muss was getan werden und twitter steht schon ein bisschen länger im fadenkreuz der diskussion weil sie eine lange zeit überhaupt nichts getan haben beziehungsweise immer eine weile gebraucht haben bis sie dann auch wirklich mal was,
getan haben kann man lange drüber diskutieren ob ihre maßnahmen immer so richtig waren werden uns als das mit dem sogenannten gamer was,
viel geld hatte aber eigentlich sich wenig mit gaming beschäftigte sondern glaube ich so im rückblick dann auch mal so als als als uh knall,
das netz mob generation angesehen werden könnte,
da musste sich halt schon fitter viele fragen gefallen lassen ob sie denn nicht mal wege finden wie man user speziell halt auch frauen im netz,
besser schützen kann vor beleidigungen vor gewaltandrohung vor,
und allem möglichen was daraus resultierte.
Und zuletzt gab's natürlich vor allem diese debatten darüber so was es eigentlich wenn ihr so ein trump,
los strampelt und im prinzip in jedem zweiten tweet diese von twitter alt heilig erachten community guideline permanent verletzt in dem man halt
falsche information beleidigen informationen rassistische kommentare et cetera veröffentlicht am laufenden meter meine mama und nichts vor.
Würde ich jetzt dieselben inhalte einfach so in ins netz blasen wie donald trump werde meinen account schon lange gesperrt gewesen.
Ja das ist das sagt ihr kennt twitter ja sogar auch an ne also sie sagen ja das richtig.
Bist du genau aber ist ja staatschef oder wieso schön sagen world lieder weil ich als vertreter der world möchte an der stelle nochmal sagen der mich leidet der untergang garantie nicht.
Ich habe dann auch.
Ich kann das schwer also ich.
So bitte so schwer es fällt ist twitter s argumentation natürlich erstmal auch selbst dienlich,
weil sie sagen,
also weil ihnen natürlich donald trump 'ne ganze ist ihr bester kunde das ist so ne wir werden einfach viele der kriegt ja viele likes und so der der hebt diese plattform,
durchaus in die relevanz und es ist nicht
da twitter ja immer noch defizite er ist und ohne irgendwelche aussicht auf nennenswerte monetarisieren übung da operiert würden die nun,
ihren besten influencer da verlieren würde das jetzt gleich mal den wert des unternehmens und den zukunftsprognose vielleicht nicht unbedingt dienlich sein.
Zumindest passiert was sie glauben wie sie sich monetarisieren.
Das ist ja da müssen wir jetzt nicht du kannst ihn ja später dann erklären wie das eigentlich machen müssen,
die haben aber natürlich auch das argument zu sagen hör mal wenn ihr hier was weiß ich wenn kim jong-un irgendetwas sagt oder donald trump dann hat das eben relevanz auch wenn es gegen sämtliche.
Auch wenn es eine lüge ist auch wenn's gegen sämtliche
regeln des zusammenlebens auf die menschen sich seit der steinzeit geeinigt haben verstößt auch wenn's gegen jeden guten geschmack verstößt und noch dazu eine lüge ist es,
den es hat einfach news welche und gesellschaftliche und historische relevanz und deswegen können wir das nicht löschen,
finde ich wie gesagt es ist selbst dienlich aber es ist auch eine gewisse weise nachvollziehbar.
Ja naja trotzdem waren sie jetzt der meinung sie müssen doch was tun.
Genau sie haben jetzt neue regeln für asoziale staatschefs.
Und zwar wenn jetzt ein staatschef,
so der quasi so ein so ein diplomaten nummernschild hat ne an seinem twitteraccount nach dem motto ich ich darf ja auch falsch parken.
Im prinzip so ein bisschen was wie diplomaten status ne,
wenn die hier irgendwie dürfen ja viele leute überfahren und so weiter und dürfen dann ausreisen und dann darf man aber nicht sagen weil es ja vom anderen land und wenn ihr also jetzt so ein diplomaten abseits der genug leute über die füße fährt,
darf der dann immer noch da sein weil es bisher dann auch dokumentiert werden aber die möglichkeit,
diese beiträge zu betreten oder zu liken die,
könnte dann entfallen also wenn dann dieser tweet gemeldet wird ich bin mir sicher jeder von,
trump wird,
auch gleich sofort gemeldet in massen ja,
wird halt irgendwo ein trump gremium also die beschäftigen bestimmt zehn leute mittlerweile nur noch die sich ausschließlich nur mit dem präsidenten beschäftigen.
Das hat auch den.
Ja dann können sie halt also entschließen beschließen dass dieser dieser dieser tweet dann nicht mehr hält fit ist und nicht mehr like.
Dementsprechend hat das dann auch auswirkungen auf die algorithmen sortierung der timeline die meiner meinung nach sowieso nicht haben will ne also wird dann halt im ranking auch entsprechend herunter gesetzt und,
außerdem soll es dann auch noch ein hinweis auf den regelverstoß geben also sowas wie ist.
Rassistisch ist falsch stimmt nicht,
das wiederum finde ich mal ganz interessant also wenn sozusagen nehmen trump tweets dann so eine offizielle einordnung kommt mit stimmt nicht.
Ja
Das wird spannend.
Sie sagen dass sie also folgende szenario aus gibt es in denen sie das machen würden bewerbungen von terrorismus.
Klare und direkte bedrohungen mit gewalt wo sie schon direkt schreiben kontext meters dann posting privat information.
Posting sharing intimität videos.
And,
ich glaube dass trump allenfalls unter das ermutigen und das verbreiten von selbst verletzungen,
fällt weil die leute sich halt auf den kopf schlagen wenn dir die scheiße lesen dieser typ schreibt aber ich wusste nicht dass er mal terrorismus wirklich promotet hätte,
jemanden mit körperlicher gewalt gedroht hätte private informationen gelegt hätte oder intime fotos veröffentlicht hätte.
Britannien von.
Ja gut der das.
Fast.
Ah da ist es auch schon wieder schwierig also da könnte man sagen dass das gewalt,
aber es ist kein direkter keine direkte drogen mit gewalt also ich bin mal gespannt ob trump am ende drunter fällt wie viele tipps von trump am ende runterfallen.
Wenn er nicht darunter fällt dann können sie können sie diese regeln auch gleich wieder einpacken.
Ja und das genau glaube ich,
aber es wäre es ist ein interessanter punkt also man muss vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz twitter ist position da.
Würdigen sie sagen alles was wir tun beginnt mit einem verständnis,
das sind unserer plattform nämlich ein ort zu schaffen an dem menschen in der öffentlichen konversation teilnehmen können,
informationen über die welt um sie herum sammeln können.
Und sagen dann halt aus diesem grund es gibt einige wenige öffentliche figuren.
Die dabei unsere regeln verletzen aber wir sagen halt es ist in dem öffentlichen interesse dass diese auch diese regel verletzungen dann eben dokumentiert bleiben.
So argumentieren sie halt ne und ja ich kann dem ich kann dir zumindest der argumentation skelette folgen,
dieser trump normalisiert.
Vollkommen inakzeptabel ist und a soziales verhalten,
welches wir uns lange bemüht haben aus unseren gesellschaften an den rand zu drängen und das uns nicht als vorbild dienen kann,
andererseits würde dann natürlich twitter entgegnen ihr habt den gewählt es kann doch jetzt nicht unsere,
aufgabe sein den in die schranken zu weisen wenn ihr so ein deppen zum staatschef gewählt habt also die diskussion ist schwierig.
Ich finde es natürlich total geil wenn ihr einfach blocken würden das wäre echt gut.
Aber du kannst die wissen natürlich auch dass das dann ihre plattform erledigt wäre das da wollen wir uns auch nix vorzumachen das werden sie nicht überleben.
Meinst du.
Guck dir das an wie viele follower da hat die würden einfach,
diese diese diese follower die der hat die würden einfach die werden wahrscheinlich,
unternehmens gebäude anzünden oder so also das wir es nicht oder also mir ist nicht vorstellbar was dann los wäre aber das wäre nicht etwas was in einem tag gegessen ist,
das wäre ein größerer größeres thema.
Ja da wird 's mal interessant sein zu sehen inwiefern.
Das meiste wie schnell der trump sich dann da auf einmal wieder für enteignung interessieren würde,
facebook hat auch ein bisschen was gemacht,
also sie haben fünfzig instagram account und ein facebook account gelöscht die insgesamt
so eine viertel million follower hatten dabei wurden,
zugeordnet haben nicht die republik armee sondern die russische fabrik.
Der sie die wo sie davon ausgehen dass sie mit der information und sonstigen die,
politische diskussion und wahl diskussion in den usa vergiften möchte er hat sich aber auch in einem ja.
Also er der zuckerberg mark zuckerberg hat in der george university eine rede gehalten am siebzehnten oktober in der er sich sehr ausführlich,
ja meinungs- und redefreiheit einsetzt.
Und sich mehr oder weniger halt facebook und seine policy dort.
Ähm als ja den weißen ritter der der der meinungsfreiheit.
Darstellt und quasi vieler gesellschaftlicher fortschritt liegt da hat nur deshalb stattgefunden weil facebook hier so eine,
tolle bastion der meinungs meinungsfreiheit ist und ähm.
Hat dafür natürlich eine ganze reihe an kritik eingesetzt bekommen weil nun.
Es ja nicht so ist als wir
in dem was sie tun durchaus kritik würde ich das ein milliarden unternehmen dass das nicht für die redefreiheit macht sondern für profite außerdem,
hat facebook natürlich eine ganze reihe an katastrophalen einflüssen auf demokratie und meinungsfreiheit und ist eben genau nicht eine plattform die meinungsfreiheit,
gleichermaßen allen zur verfügung stellt sondern eine plattform die zugang zu öffentlichkeit verkauft und zu ihrem business modell macht die für so phänomene für wie,
brexit und trump eine verrohung des diskurses und sonstiges steht und sich davon auch nicht frei machen kann indem sie sich jetzt irgendwie als weiß ritter,
darstellen denn.
Das was so sehr ich die position zur meinungsfreiheit teile ja ich bin ich glaube auch dass es nicht,
uns irgendwie weiterbringt äußerungen,
einzudämmen meinungsfreiheit einzuschränken wir müssen der weg nach vorne ist ein weg der über die meinungsfreiheit geht,
wir können nicht
progressiven fortschritt machen indem wir jetzt irgendwie diese afd noten versuchen weg zu zensieren,
oder trump wegzuziehen sie das wird nicht das problem lösen dass jetzt im zweifelsfall vergrößern ich
in diesem punkt gehe ich ihm schon noch würde ich mit ihm mitgehen aber facebook als algorithmus maschine,
die eigentlich nur dafür da ist menschen süchtig zu machen,
hat echt mal in in der diskussion um meinungsfreiheit wirklich die schnauze zu halten
weil diese meinungsfreiheit von der sie da reden ist das was sie letztendlich verkaufen und menschen dürfen es von mir aus meinungsfreiheit haben.
Aber das ist ja hier äh das heißt ja nicht dass sie auch die freiheit haben gehört zu werden und was facebook ist ist eine maschine die es den menschen ermöglicht,
gehört zu werden sei es dadurch dass sie gezielt mit den,
spielregeln von facebook spielen und riet fitz und pipapo und filter babels und sonstiges nutzen oder sei es dadurch dass sie sich ganz einfach da den zugang zur öffentlichkeit kaufen und jemand der in diesem geschäft ist,
und der so etwas geschaffen hat soll bitte nicht von meinungsfreiheit sprechen das ist ein bisschen.
Dann haben wir noch auch meinungsfreiheit hält auch unter meinungsfreiheit,
würde ich sagen der bbc lagebericht.
Kann man schon mal also dürfte ja sagen was ihr wollt.
Es ist immer wieder auf eine gewisse weise also der lagebericht ist immer sehr.
Tja eine also.
Eine eine schöne zeit im jahr der wessi lager bricht wird jedes jahr veröffentlicht und darin werden wird geschildert,
ja was das denn so gibt also so eine art
erstens schon rechtfertigung und tätigkeitsbereich des bbs andererseits ein bericht der eben quasi das
die risiko risiko lage darstellen soll und quasi ein bisschen sagt so wie sieht's aus dem silber ne
wie steht die da stellt sich raus beschissen als letztes jahr das ist also ähnlich wie logbuch politik eigentlich der der lagebericht was ich immer ein bisschen traurig finde ist dass die,
tatsächlich nicht in der lage zu sein scheinen aus dem was sie da beobachten,
konsequenzen zu ziehen ja so sagen ja klar eine der größten cyber bedrohung ist irgendwie emotion ist das ist einfach das was gerade den,
unternehmen probleme macht ja sie erkennen aber zum beispiel oder sagen dann hier im kammergericht berlin war jetzt irgendwie befall sie
sprechen da ausführlich drüber erkennt aber nicht,
zieh dich den schluss einfach mal zu sagen folgende schritte wären nötig um dieses problem zu begegnen und der erste schritt wäre microsoft in in in die vernunft zu ziehen.
Und dafür zu sorgen dass die mal einen sinnvollen effektiven schritt dagegen unternehmen dass leute dazu interessiert werden,
markus auszuführen aus uns aus nicht vertrauenswürdig der quelle ich habe das hier vor einigen wochen schon angemerkt mit signierten markus mit dieser funktion einfach mal von vornherein auszuschalten
und und und und und ja also wir haben in dieser,
mehr menschliche schwachstellen die eine rolle spielen,
und wir haben ein bh das hauptsächlich damit beschäftigt ist zu sagen ja wir haben eine training wir haben eine verhalten bei it's not fällen dina vier blatt was man irgendwo aufkleben kann und ansonsten haben wir 'ne ganze reihe
toller technischer initiativen und computer netze sicherer zu machen und das ist natürlich nicht.
Das ist einfach nicht der punkt der die arbeiten halt nicht an den problemen die wir die wir gerade beobachten und das ist immer wieder relativ
relativ traurig halt diese diese hilflosigkeit zu sehen mit der das da eigentlich agiert ja und,
interessanterweise sagen sie dann.
Sagen sie die unnötig verschärft wird die lage durch die oft festzustellen digitale hilflosigkeit auf seiten der anwender ja also am ende machen sie noch das was man dem blauling nennt ja,
und erkennen nicht dass das ihre aufgabe wäre daran etwas zu ändern,
w w w für bürger de und da müssen sie vielleicht mal irgendwie dann doch über eine,
i notfallkarte die ja natürlich bei uns auch in der mitte eben an der wand hängt wir haben das ja,
wie war einfach nochmal wie war nochmal die notfall nummer tim.
Null eins eins acht neun neun neun acht acht eins neun neun neun eins eins neun sieben zwei fünf drei.
Wir nehmen die angebote des ihr an ja aber zusammen hilflos das volkes hilflos da draußen ist der da draußen tobt der russe.
Das war der lageberichtes so das ist.
Der cyber krieg da draus macht die tür zu schließt die ports ab zieht alle kabel raus.
Ja das wäre also wirklich toll wenn sie da mal auch versuchen würden zu agieren,
und auch mal irgendwie die bedrohungslage also man liest sich immer so ihre empfehlungen fast losgelöst sind von der schilderung das ist immer so so was was da draußen los,
und was haben wir gemacht so,
fünfhunderttausend schlüssel wurden im dunklen park verloren deswegen suchen wir unter der laterne ja das ist irgendwie so dass der basti lagebericht.
Ja und es gab auch attacken übers wlan daraufhin haben wir alle unsere w-lan kabel rausgezogen.
Herr je ja ähm die bundesregierung kommt auch nicht voran,
hätte damit gerechnet ne da gibt's.
Erstmal eine sehr schöne sehr schönen kommentar auf der seite tagesschau die ich finde das immer schön wenn loko netzwerk berichtet ja von woche zu woche ich freue mich immer wenn wir gelegenheit haben dann mal so ein bisschen in den ein bisschen zurückzublicken wo jetzt hier,
kommentiert wird von christian feld vom ndr der sagt eigentlich sollte ja bis ende zwanzig achtzehn alle haushalte in deutschland mindestens fünfzig mbit haben.
Zumindest in die eine richtung.
Ja wir wollten außerdem eine verlässliche und lückenlose mobilfunk versorgung im ländlichen raum insbesondere im ländlichen raum also.
Und er stellt aber fest dass finde ich sehr gut also er würde ich auch die fortschritte ja,
zitat in einzelnen bundesländern ist es mittlerweile möglich das elterngeld online zu beantragen.
Du das ist ne.
Auch ein slow club ist ein clip.
Fordert genau und ja der digitalpakt schule der ja hier bei uns auch mal als gute nachricht gibt feature wurde,
steckt also jetzt daran fest dass bis jetzt noch nicht alle bundesländer eine entsprechende förderrichtlinien fertig haben das heißt die meisten schulen werden auf ihre fördergelder noch etwas warten müssen das ist gar nicht so schlecht
hauptsache die haben sich jetzt schon die angebote eingeholt weil wenn sie glück haben noch ein bisschen warten dann kriegen sie halt auch nicht vergangen zu veralteten scheiß für ihre fördern.
Ja auf jeden fall gab so ein paar oppositions anträge die natürlich dann abgeschmettert wurden weil zum beispiel teilweise kam das von den grünen teilweise,
das ist ein einzelnen geist auf dröseln auf jeden fall wurde unter anderem das war tatsächlich eine fdp antrag der antrag abgelehnt ob sie nicht vielleicht noch ein digitalministerium eingeführt werden sollte wäre doch vielleicht mal eine ganz geile idee.
Ja nee geht alles nicht haben anders besprochen da müssen wir wieder ein minister aufstellen es gibt nur streit.
Sie müssen wir ja wählen was was es kostet.
Nee ich finde auch wir brauchen kein digitalministerium wir haben ja wenn man die dorothee bär.
Kennst du noch.
Ja die.
Lange nichts mehr von gehört mit anderen worten doro bearbeite gerade ganz ganz fleißig wenn man nichts mehr von ihr hört die muss die wird bestimmt mit einer ganz ganz dicken nummer demnächst kommen ja.
Weißt du ich bin gespannt meine vielleicht,
wir müssen langsam zu ende kommen aber diese idee mit einem digitalministerium.
Meine all das man kann,
so am ende hat's mir mit kompetenz und wille zu tun und beides scheint nicht so verbreitet zu sein in der aktuellen politiker generation und das ist einfach auch getränke,
mangel an real erlebnissen in der eigenen jugend weil da einfach das digitale noch nicht so präsent.
Das mache ich mal so als ursprung grund aus.
Mittlerweile ändert sich das natürlich langsam und die frage ist wie kann man den strukturell entgegentreten die idee eines digitalministerium finde ich insofern reizvoll auch wenn ich das jetzt bis zu ende gedacht habe,
würde mich mal interessieren wie du das siehst einfach so als,
so ähnlich wie eben ein finanzministerium überall noch mit reinreden darf und das quasi so wie es ein finanz vorbehalt gibt eben auch generell so ein digital vorbehalten.
Nee.
Ja
so nach dem motto ja okay schön dass ihr das jetzt umsetzen wollt schön dass ihr da irgendwie eure dass ihr da irgendwie eure rechtsanwälte auf einmal digital kommunizieren soll aber wir haben ein digital vorbehalt weil das muss alles in ein großes system passen das muss
muss sozusagen mit unserem digitalen protokoll etat zusammenpassen ihr könnt nicht irgendwelche maßnahmen
machen die jetzt nicht sozusagen das große ganze mit reinpassen oder die dich den zielen des großen und ganzen entsprechend ja also ihr macht zu wenig um irgendwie das gesamt ziele zu erreichen
was man halt natürlich vorher nochmal.
Also den digital vorbehalt finde ich eine großartige idee tatsächlich
ich will nur mal wenn man jetzt mal sagt man setzt das nicht in so eine zustimmung richtige rolle na wenn wir jetzt mal überlegen wofür wir uns ministerien gönnen ja immer eine auswahl das bundesministerium des innern für bau und heimat
das bundesministerium für wirtschaft und energie auswärtige amt bundesministerium der justiz und verbraucherschutz,
ministerium für arbeit und soziales ministerium der verteidigung ministerium für energie für ernährung und landwirtschaft für familie senioren,
frauen und jugend für gesundheit für umwelt und naturschutz und nukleare sicherheit für verkehr und digitale infrastruktur für bildung und forschung für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit,
und entwicklung da sind paar ministerien die wir haben da stellt sich ja wohl also würden wir schätzen dass vielleicht das digitale in unserer gesellschaft.
Vorbehalten sich der idee dass sich das internet tatsächlich am ende durchsetzen könnte ich mir vorstellen,
das unter umständen mal eine rolle spielt wie,
ernährung und landwirtschaft oder wie senioren frauen und jugend.
Na eigentlich halt mehr so.
Genau es ist net aber mindestens ein ministerium und dann mit digital vorbehalt das problem ist natürlich wir haben ja wir haben ja wie war das eigentlich mit der mit dem.
Mit dem in kraft treten dieser großen koalition sind jedoch eigentlich davon ausgegangen dass sie jetzt mit dem scheuer.
Den verkehrsminister scheuer in für digitale infrastruktur digital minister haben da haben sie gesagt die doro bär da ist 'ne ist jetzt eine internet ministerin und innenminister auch nochmal ne.
Oder das wirtschaftsministerium.
Und wirtschaftsminister.
Verloren wer sich jetzt alles gerade zuständig findet.
So nicht so nicht so ist falsch.
Jesus nicht.
Aber auch bitte nicht sind also dem scheuer muss man sowieso jetzt mal langsam alles wegnehmen bevor wir demnächst hier noch eine internet maut haben.
Der typ ey das ist keine hast du hast du mitbekommen ne.
Ich habe einiges mitbekommen ich fand eigentlich die idee mit dem mit dem einfacheren motorrad führerschein ganz gut das kann auch ruhig nochmal machen.
Das kann auch noch machen sozusagen eine ordentliche maut der hat ja diese verträge mit dem betreiber firmen.
Unterzeichneten mit einem klaren massiven finanziellen nachteil für die regierung also für uns als der zeit den ganzen scheiß wir und kein wenn
das nicht zustande kommt da hat er seinen europa rechtswidrigen scheiß da durchgeführt jetzt kriegt ihr das nicht durch und wir dürfen jetzt dafür zahlen dass er die verträge unterschrieben hat,
bevor er wusste ob er rechtssicherheit dafür hat das eine knallt hüte.
Das war wirklich handwerklich unzureichend.
Kann man so sagen.
Ja kann man so sagen tim man sieht du guckst viel brexit debatten
da könnte ich mir auch vorstellen dass jetzt das so der der ehrbare gentleman andreas scheuer hat hier eine arbeit geliefert die handwerklich nicht den ansprüchen der majestät genügt ja so könnte man.
So könnte man das etwas sagen.
So komm wir machen.
Königin ist nicht amüsiert.
Die krone ist nicht so komm mach mal termin melodie.
Klar mache ich doch glatt hallo weil wir einen termin haben oder.
Können wir auch nochmal loben die ist ja von.
Alle die die termine melodie die ist ja von der gar nicht sagen der war gar nicht sagen verwende ist ne kann man nicht loben nicht.
Ne das verboten die wir jetzt auch nicht aber wir spielen sie trotzdem.
Aux
Im november und zwar vom ersten bis dritten november findet zum dritten mal das frei funkt festival statt unter dem motto,
menschen mischen öfter dezentral also menschen mit in geschweißt klammern.
Mix aus vorträgen social leisen eine oder andere getränk wird es wahrscheinlich auch geben der,
oldenburger mainstream main frame hat dafür die lokalität bereitgestellt und er bietet auf,
eintausendzweihundert quadratmetern boah oldenburg wurde offenbar noch nicht äh gentrifizierten da gibt's noch.
Neulich ausreichend zumindest gibt's noch was.
Also erster bis dritter november frei vom festival zwanzig neunzehn in oldenburg.
Außerdem gibt es noch ein veranstaltungsort gebot in frankfurt denn da wird geburtstag gefeiert vom fc frankfurt das ganze bereits am sechzehnten november zweitausendneunzehn geht's,
um achtzehn uhr los in den räumen des fc frankfurt in der kasse zwei und da,
ist offensichtlich auch für alles gesorgt was soll das hessische herz begehrt.
Zehn jahre zehn jahre bestehen voll feiern die und mir fällt jetzt gerade ein wir hatten mich eigentlich darum gebeten das nicht im lok voran zu kündigen weil sie nicht so viel platz haben also kündigt euch.
Also kündigt euch mal kündigt euch mal anwenden.
Geht da nicht hin auf keinen fall.
Ich habe mein facebook-event angelegt.
Man kann sich ich ihr könnt euch da könnt euch da ankündigen und bescheid sagen.
Ein so was können wir so was können wir na gut dann.
Denn was das frei.
Dann war's das jetzt im wesentlichen genau reicht auch ihr habt so wie seid ihr sowieso total über versorgt in letzter zeit hier durch logbuch politik.
Aber ich stimme jetzt noch hier bei der spd ab weil ich hab ja gesehen da kann man sich auch einfach so registrieren.
Ja aber es funktioniert nur in der ersten phase der zweite phase schicken sie dann doch nochmal eine mail an die zurück gespeicherte zurück gelegte.
Klingt total.
Seid ihr auch gleich machen können also wenn sie ihr schon haben.
Okay damit sind wir am ende die spd auch und ich danke dem julian.
Ja das ist gut.
Und ich danke allen die wieder eingeschaltet haben macht es auch beim nächsten mal wieder.
Aux